[Music]
that was a scene from The Nutcracker the
holiday classic that's been performed by
the New York City Ballet for more than
50 years but this year the timeless
production actually features something
new Elaine Quijano is here with the
story Elaine good morning good morning
11 year old Charlotte neveress is the
first black dancer to win the coveted
role of Murray the young heroine of the
Nutcracker story and her story is just
one example of the changing face of the
world of classical dance each year
students from the famed School of
American Ballet star in this annual
presentation of the Nutcracker this
school was founded by world-renowned
choreographer George Balanchine in 1934
as a place to nurture young talent who
could then move on to the elite stage of
the New York City Ballet but for dancers
of color getting there often meant
encountering invisible barriers when you
are minority in any environment there's
an added struggle Ayesha Ashe attended
this school in the 1990s and performed
with the New York City Ballet for more
than seven years she says it was
sometimes this small things like not
having proper hair products or stage
makeup that sent a message about whether
she truly belong I remember the girls I
got in with you know were given many
different palettes and things to choose
from and you know I sort of got a
lipstick and that was pretty much it and
maybe a powder it was like I don't
really have much for you they didn't
have anything with your skin tone with
my skin tone these things they're not
said maliciously you know it's just that
just was the art but you just sort of
feel yourself drifting more and more
away and feeling more and more separate
than everyone else
ash now sits on the Diversity Committee
at the School of American Ballet and her
experiences have helped pave the way for
this moment
eleven-year-old Charlotte neveress whose
grandparents hail from Trinidad in the
Philippines soaring on center stage at
Lincoln Center
the first black ballerina ever to play
the lead role here in the Nutcracker
since 1954 there's never been a Marie
that looks like you what do you think
about that well at first when I found
that out it was a little bit surprising
but then it's like in that well if I'm
going to be doing this role and I'm the
first person then I want to make it
count so I really wanted to make it
special for everyone in the audience and
for the people on the stage as well
Charlotte's mother danielle was born and
raised in new york city and says it
wasn't long ago when this kind of
opportunity wouldn't have been possible
for her daughter it's sort of magical
for me to see that sort of just
hopefulness and just realizing that
there is no limit so I'm sort of
learning through her that maybe the way
things were aren't what they are any
longer now dancers are given makeup and
hair products to enhance their features
not alter them one thing that they made
clear to us is that she didn't have to
change her hair now that she has this
big role as Marie they don't want to
change her they want her as she is and
for you know women of color for black
women that's that's very important to
know that you are enough and you're
beautiful as you are and you don't need
to change who you are sending that
message is now a priority for the school
we wanted to open up communication face
to face between the artistic staff and
the dancers to hear their concerns
former dancer Jonathan Stafford took
over as artistic director earlier this
year after ballet master in chief Peter
Martin's retired amidst abuse
allegations Stafford intends to change
the culture including making casting
decisions that better reflect the city's
population what would you say to folks
who wonder why has it taken so long well
they're absolutely right it has taken
too long
unfortunately the country we live in
there's been policies and practices that
have been codified from a very very
early times
and then strengthened over the years
that don't allow equal opportunity for
every person and ballet was very much a
European art form when it came over to
this country it was based on standards
of beauty that were very European and
very white and it just took the dance
world in New York City Ballet a long
time to first recognize it and then to
change it
that also means shaping audience
perceptions something Ayesha Ashe is
trying to do off stage in her Swan
dreams project it's an ongoing photo
essay that includes striking images of
her in her hometown of Rochester New
York while we're trying to create more
black ballerinas we also have to change
the the perception that those who are
coming to the ballet have of women of
color we are multi-dimensional and we
are also soft and graceful and angelic
and ethereal and society needs to see us
in that way so that when they come to
the ballet and they see that black or
brown princess on the stage it's well of
course suit a mission the School of
American Ballet shares we're in a
position to tell people what is
beautiful and we can change people's
idea of what is beautiful by what we put
on the stage and that's a responsibility
that we take very very seriously and by
putting some dancers on the stage that
are longtime audience goers maybe hadn't
seen before it's gonna change people's
perception of what ballet is what a
ballet dancer is for Aisha Ashe it's a
full circle moment it's so nice to meet
you sweetheart I think less about what
it means to me and I think much more
about what it's going to mean to all of
those little girls that see her white
and black that see her and can see
themselves and see a chance see an
opportunity that's huge
what is it that you hope people watching
in the audience feel or think about when
they see you performing on stage well I
want them to feel empowered because
you got to see someone like you on stage
and it makes you think oh well maybe I
can do that too because if she did it
than I can in addition to Charlotte the
other three children who played Leeds in
this year's Nutcracker are also
multiracial Jonathan Stafford the
artistic director says because the
available pool of talent is now bigger
those who dance in lead roles truly
represent the best in the ballet world
today yes a BA has really done a great
job of bringing diversity into the
forefront but I understand Charlie got
another little surprise with it she did
from her other mentor misty Copeland so
this was so fun to watch she was
appointed principal dancer misty
Copeland was at another company the
American Ballet Theatre and she was
actually in the audience at a recent
Nutcracker performance Charlotte was
transfixed the very first time that she
saw misty perform so this was another
full circle moment misty congratulated
Charlotte on her accomplishment it's
what Charlotte said at the end there
when you see somebody we say this so
many times when you see somebody who
looks like you doing something suddenly
your mind is open to that pastas
important to see a diversity of people
on that thank you
Elaine